okay let's go to our next caller from
the two four zero area code something up
with the phones today I think let's go
who's calling from two four zero and
where are you calling from Eric hey
alright so Eric listen something's going
on with your phone every third word it
sounds like you're underwater is that is
there anything we might be able to do
about them just barely just barely
let's try I'm gonna let's try it one
more time what was your question I
called you three weeks ago can you hear
me yes you called three weeks ago okay I
called you about three weeks ago and we
got into it about the Trump Tower
meeting being a set up and I saw that
you posted it on your YouTube channel it
rings a bell it rings a bell yeah yes
see news letter I guess you can call it
says Trump dossier firm which is fusion
GPS also supplied info used in Trump
Tower meeting and the second paragraph
says in NBC News Russian lawyer
Natalia ethnics kaya she received
supposed incriminating evidence for the
tomtom meeting um fusion GPS owner Glen
center okay that and then you said I was
disconnected from reality and you hung
up on me
okay I don't remember the specifics of
the conversation I don't I also just I'm
lacking the context to know what the
paragraph you read how it relates to
what you're asserting but if you email
it to me I'll take a look at it well
exactly to what I was asserting I told
you that it was a setup by fusing GPS
which is a Democrat Party up research
firm and then I said that the lady was
sent in by fusing GPS Glenn Simpson was
the founder in the owner and you said
I'm
connected from reality and I can't walk
in true bubble them at the same time or
something of that nature I I that's not
really a greater use so the fact that
you're attributing a phrase like that to
me makes me question your recollection
of it but listen Eric I don't remember
exactly what you're talking about
and your audios going in and out so can
you email me what you're talking about
and I'll look at it certainly okay thank
you appreciate the call I will look at
that and we will research and follow-up